T
NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT AND I
WANTED A SISTER.
>> Tucker: I DON'T EVEN KNOW
THIS PERSON WHO CLAIMS TO BE MY
SISTER!
WHO TO BELIEVE?
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING TO SPEAK TO
MEGHAN MARKLE'S SISTER SAMANTHA
MARKEL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
TONIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF HER CLAIM
THAT SHE HAS NO IDEA WHO YOU
ARE?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
WOW.
IT'S BEEN A SERIES OF LIES AND I
CAN'T BELIEVE WE WERE
ESSENTIALLY LOOKING AT A
$100 MILLION FAKE NEWS P.R.
MACHINE.
ITS PROJECTION AT ITS FINEST AND
IT'S ALMOST COMICAL.
SO NOT TRUE AND THE WHOLE
GRANDMOTHER THING, THAT JUST DID
IT FOR US.
I THINK MY GRANDMOTHER WOULD BE
ROLLING OVER IN HER GRAVE IF SHE
SAW THAT AND SHE DIDN'T TAKE
CARE OF HER.
SHE VISITED HER, SHE NEVER MADE
APPLE BUTTER WITH HER, MY
GRANDMOTHER WAS MAKING APPLE
BUTTER IN THE 1970s BEFORE
MEGHAN WAS BORN.
IT'S A TRAGICOMEDY SADLY FOR OUR
FAMILY AND FOR THE ROYALS.
AND HERE WE ARE.
>> Tucker: SHE DOESN'T SEEM TO
HAVE LEFT QUITE A TRAIL OF
DESTRUCTION IN HER WAKE BUT SHE
ALSO HAS AS YOU POINTED OUT IN
YOUR FIRST SENTENCE
$8,100,000,000 P.R. MACHINE ON
HER SIDE TO TELLING HER STORY IN
SOFT FOCUS.
WHAT'S IT LIKE TO BE UP AGAINST
THAT?
>> THAT'S BEEN ON CONTINUUM, I
FOUND OUT FROM LONDON THERE WAS
AN ENTRENCHED MEDIA AGENDA
AGAINST ME BACK IN 2018.
THERE HAS BEEN A SERIES OF FAKE
NEWS STORIES AND I COULDN'T
FIGHT IT, LET'S FACE IT.
COMPANIES THAT ARE POWER HOUSES
ARE REALLY POWERFUL AND SO IS
THE PRINTED WORD.
WE DIDN'T KNOW HOW WE WERE GOING
TO DEAL WITH IT UNTIL THEY SAY
WATER SEEKS ITS OWN LEVEL.
EVENTUALLY THE TRUTH COMES OUT
AND WHEN IT DOES AND THE DUST
SETTLES I THOUGHT TRUTH HAS TO
STAND FOR SOMETHING, TRUTH WINS.
HERE WE ARE.
>> Tucker: I THINK IT DOES.
SHE HAS BEEN ABLE TO KEEP THE
TRUTH AT BAY -- THIS IS MY
READ -- BY ACCUSING ANYONE WHO
HAS QUESTIONS AND CRITICIZES HER
OF RACISM, HAS SHE CALLED YOU A
RACIST YET, YOUR SISTER?
>> NO, THERE WERE SOME WEIRD
P.R. STORIES IN THE BEGINNING
THAT ALLUDED TO THAT BUT IS NOT
REALISTIC.
WE WERE ON INTERRACIAL FAMILY.
IF WE LOOK BACK ON WHEN THEY
WERE JET-SETTING, LOOKING BACK
AT THAT CULTURAL WEDDING AND
PRINCE CHARLES HAD PAID FOR AND
CHOSEN THE CHOIR AND THE BISHOP
I HEARD.
THERE WASN'T ANY RACISM THERE
UNTIL A POINT AT WHICH THEY
BEGAN BEING CRITICIZED FOR
MAKING HOLLYWOOD DEALS WHILE
THEY WERE WORKING ROYALS.
WORK AT McDONALD'S, ANYWHERE
YOU WORK, THERE IS PROHIBITED
CONDUCT, THERE ARE RULES, THERE
ARE BOUNDARIES.
IT SEEMS TO ME THEY GOT INTO
THEIR POSITION, THEY HAD A LOT
OF FUN, THEY LOVE THE ACCOLADES
AND THE PERKS BUT WHEN IT CAME
TIME TO BEING ACCOUNTABLE AND
RESPONSIBLE AND FOLLOWING RULES,
THAT SEEMS TO BE WHEN EVERYTHING
FELL APART.
THAT'S LIFE.
I DON'T SEE THE RACISM, RACISM,
SOMEBODY CALL THE WAMBULANCE.
>> Tucker: I'M STEALING THAT.
YOU HAVE ANY ADVICE, WHAT WOULD
YOU COUNSEL THEM?
>> I THINK APATHY IN A SITUATION
LIKE THIS WHEN YOU ARE DEALING
WITH SOMEONE WHO APPEARS TO LACK
EMPATHY, REMORSE, OR SHAME,
EMPATHY CAN BE A DANGEROUS THING
AND SO CAN APATHY, YOU NEED TO
LAY DOWN THE BOUNDARIES BECAUSE
THEY SEEM TO NOT LIKE BOUNDARIES
AND I THINK IT SETS A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT TO LET THIS GO ON.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT